live in west hollywood
and she's one of the first things she's
like are you gay and i was like no i'm
not gay and she's like oh thank god and
i was like
you know there's west hollywood
everybody's gay
i was like you're in the wrong business
if you this is where you have your
building and she said the the with the
man who was in this here he died before
he you come here i was like oh oh
that's terrible she goes of aids but you
know he was gay and i was like oh okay
the way she threw it away
yeah man i was like this homophobic
landlord in the middle of west hollywood
i was like what are you doing in this
neighborhood
yeah i was like you're in the wrong spot
sell the building if you don't like